should I do what I'm good at or what I'm
passionate about this answer is easy for
me and the answer is always passion
because if you are just doing what
you're good at
and you hate doing it you're not gonna
be happy you're gonna be one of the
people climbing the corporate ladder
waiting for the weekend to happen when
you really live your life okay that's
not the life that you want now ideally
you your your passion or something and
you're good at it but given the choice
between the two always follow your
passion this comes as a result from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys
purpose speaks who wrote in about one of
my radio shows and on my radio show I
had an interview with a guy named Mark
who was a top seller on Fiverr where you
sell projects at five dollars at a time
and then can upsell people purpose
speaks wrote in to say basically I'm
good at it in photos but it's not a
passion and your opinion should the
service you offer on Fiverr does it need
to be something you're passionate about
or something that you're just good at
given the option I would always pick
something I'm passionate about
and what I would encourage you to do if
you're looking at websites like Fiverr
think about what you're passionate about
and how you can break that down into
something that you can sell for five
dollars
the idea with Fiverr is you're selling
things five bucks at a time and after
you get to a certain point you can
increase how much people are spending
with you so the base father goes five
bucks but then you can upsell them on a
$10 product or $30 product or more but
that's only gonna work it's only gonna
be it's only gonna help you if it's
something that you're passionate about
here's an example Kate photo-editing you
don't like photo editing and you're good
at it and you would do it on Fiverr for
five bucks at a time but you don't like
it do you think a business that you
don't like is gonna be successful
imagine every order that comes in you
like ah I gotta go do another picture
yeah it's five bucks is actually four
because it Fiverr takes a one dollar
commission so another four bucks but I
gotta go edit this picture and you're
almost gonna hate the orders coming in
because you have more work to do and the
more those come in the less time you
have to work on your reel
business and it's gonna hold you back
so always pick something that you're
excited about something you look forward
to the more you get locked into doing
something that you're good at they're
harder it's gonna be to break free of it
to do something that you really want to
do and you see this with people who are
starting their jobs and they're on their
career path and it's easier at the start
you know when you're when you just had a
university to to break free and do
whatever you want but once you're 10 20
30 years in and you've got a mortgage
you've got a family you've got kids
that's hard to break out of that most
people wake up and they go to a job that
they hate every day because it pays the
bills because they're good at it but not
because they love it and if you want to
build a real business it can start on
Fiverr in a tiny small bite-sized chunk
just take whatever you love doing and
break it down into the smallest
component because those are the sales
people will feel your passion for it
okay if you're just good at it whatever
but if you love it and you pour your
heart into it they're gonna order more
they're gonna tell their friends about
it
they're gonna buy more from you they're
gonna they're gonna take more the
upscale offerings that you have this
could help launch your company but it's
not going to do it if you're just doing
it for the money you'll never be
successful if you're just doing it for
the money you've got to do it for a
reason you've got to do it because
you're passionate about it you got to do
it because you know you're helping
people and you're making a meaningful
difference and impact in this world
that's why you do it you do it to do it
and money will come when you're offering
tons of value to people but again any
time you're giving the choice which is
something you're good at and something
that you're passionate about passion
wins every time believe those you're
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes you want
to do more for you and then we know what
you're thinking leave a comment
underneath you have a question for me
leave it below I'll make a video
response to you on YouTube thank you so
much and I'll see you soon